multiply 6 times 1 4 simplify your
answer and write it as a mixed number so
let's just do the multiplication
so at first when you try to multiply 6
times 1 4 you'll be like well gee you
know i know how i know how to multiply a
fraction times a fraction i know how to
multiply a whole number times a whole
number but what about a whole number
times a fraction and kind of the key
insight you need here is that any whole
number can be written as a fraction we
can rewrite 6 we can rewrite 6 as 6 over
1 right 6 divided by 1 is 6. 6 ones is
6. depending on how you think about it
this is exactly the same thing as 6. so
we just rewrote our whole number as a
fraction you could do that for any
number 10 is the same thing as 10 over
1. so this becomes 6 over 1 times
6 over 1 times 1 4
times 1 4 and then we just multiply the
fractions so we multiply the numerators
so this is equal to 6 times 1 as our
numerator let me do that in another
color
so this becomes 6 times 1 for our
numerator and 1 times 4 for our
denominator for the number on the bottom
and so this will become six over four
and right now it's just as an improper
fraction and it's also not in lowest
terms you immediately see six and four
are both divisible by two so let's
divide them both by two if you divide
six by two i'll do a new color again you
divide 6 by 2 you get 3 you divide 4 by
2 you get 2. so this is equal to
3 halves so it's still written as an
improper fraction we now have to write
it as a mixed number and the process for
writing it as a mixed number you just
divide the
denominator into the numerator so this
just becomes
this just becomes 2
into 3
divide 2 into 3. it goes 2 goes into 3
one time 1 times 2 is 2 you subtract you
have a remainder of
1. so this will become so this is this
will become
one whole
one whole and
one over two left over
and one
over
two so this is one and one half so
that's all right an answer we've just
simplified the answer and wrote it as a
mixed number or we could simplify it at
this stage we could say right here well
look we could divide what's eventually
going to be in the numerator by 2 and
get a 3 there and divide what's
eventually in the denominator by 2 and
get a 2 there 3 times 1 is three
one times two is two so it's three
halves and you do this exact same
process say that three halves is the
same thing as one and one half either
either one of those will work and let's
think about why this makes sense let's
think about what six times one-fourth is
let's let's draw let me draw one-fourth
let's say that that is one-fourth right
there and let's do six of them so that's
one-fourths that's two-fourths
this three-fourths that's four-fourths
which would be a whole and then you have
five-fourths
and then you have six-fourths so this is
six times one-fourth
six times one-fourth this right here is
four-fourths this right here is four
over four which is equal to a one so
this is equal to one and then this right
here is two one-fourths or this right
here is
two-fourths and you could draw you could
imagine this is two out of a potential
if a hole has to have two more of them
has to have four of them so this is one
and
one end let me do the same colors one
one and
one half
right two out of four is the same thing
as one over two so this right here is
one out of a possible out of a possible
one and then
two
so this is one and one half
one and one half which is exactly what
we got before